إنها مشكلة لم تتعامل معها باربي أبدًا
قبل فيلمها، كعبي على الأرض
في العالم الحقيقي، الأقدام المسطحة قد تكون
شيئًا يستحق الصراخ، كما تقول
طبيبة الأقدام لوري جرانت من أورلاندو هيلث،
قدمك هي كريم الأساس الخاص بك، لذلك
عندما يكون كريم الأساس مسطحًا أو عندما يكون
كريم الأساس  هو في الواقع يؤثر على
كل شيء فوقه، فهو يؤثر على
ركبتيك، ووركك، وأسفل ظهرك،
ووضعياتك، تقول غرانت إن الحالة يمكن أن
تزيد أيضًا من خطر حدوث مشاكل مثل التهاب
اللفافة الأخمصية، ومشاكل في الكاحل، والأورام أو
مسامير القدم، ومسامير القدم، وتقول إنه من
المهم بالنسبة لأولئك الذين لديهم أقدام مسطحة أن
التعرف عليه مبكرًا بمجرد أن نتمكن من حصولك
على حذاء جيد، دعم جيد، يمكننا
إيقاف بعض عمليات التشوه، لكن
الإمساك به هو المفتاح لأولئك الذين غالبًا ما
يرتدون الكعب العالي لفترات طويلة من الوقت،
يقول جرانت أن يقتصر ارتفاع الحذاء على
حوالي اثنين  بوصة وتأكد من وجود
منصة تحت أصابع قدميك إذا
كان الكعب أعلى، قم أخيرًا بتمديد الجزء الخلفي
من قدمك بمجرد خلع الكعب
مع مرور الوقت، وتقول إن الكعب يمكن أن يؤدي في الواقع إلى
تقصير وتر العرقوب الخاص بك والذي يمكن أن
يساهم تمامًا في نفس
المشاكل التي تعاني منها باربي  كان لدي
دقيقة في المنزل أنا ماندي جايثر